déjà amélie votre fille donc à 9 ans
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait
comment elle a mangé donc une pizza une
vraie shop mais qu'est ce qu'est ce qui
s'est passé après bell a consommé une
pizza enfin de même la manger de la
pizza au fromage de l'épisode bolognaise
le mercredi 16 février
ça allait très bien et le mardi 22
février à la commencé à être malade elle
avait des signes de gastro un fort effet
une semaine après un petit peu moi ça
six jours après donc c'est sinon ça
allait bien c'est vraiment ça allait
bien sinon jusqu'à lors le mardi d'après
elle a dessiné a commencé les malades
comme une gastro elle avait des
diarrhées elle avait très très mal au
ventre elle avait des nausées mais elle
vomissait pas donc j'ai été chez le
médecin généraliste j'ai consulté le
jeudi qui m'a dit qu'elle avait
certainement une gastro entérite
certainement une grosse gastro comme un
rotavirus elle m'a demandé de faire un
prélèvement de celles que j'ai fait dans
la journée elle m'a donné un traitement
pour la gastro et la nuit de vendredi à
samedi
vers 1h du matin ma fille elle a
commencé de vomir chose qu'elle faisait
pas l'été nos yeux zoom elle vomissait
pas elle a vomi 3 4 fois et vers 5h45 du
matin j'ai trouvé elle avait un teint
cireux elle était elle vomissait mais
c'était
c'était pas comme une pièce trop j'avais
l'impression je chantais qu'elle n'était
pas bien elle se mettait partir donc je
suis parti j'ai consulté aux urgences
pédiatriques à saint-etienne et ils
m'ont tout de suite pris en charge ils
ont fait des bilans et là tout de suite
été muté en réanimation donc au départ à
saint-etienne le samedi et en fait son
état il en tirait donc le lendemain on
m'a parlé d'hémodialyse
quand j'ai demandé ma fille si elle
allait mourir on nous disait qu'on
pouvait pas me répondre on savait pas
donc le dimanche on nous a muté mafia et
hélicos porter a lâché fait mieux à lyon
parce que sur saint-etienne elle était
trop petite elle pouvait pas être
hémodialyse et donc on est allé arrivé
le dimanche nous on la suivait en
voiture et le lundi elle est passée au
bloc pour lui imposer un sheldon à
cathéter d'hémodialyse elle a été
modélisé on est restés six jours en
réanimation a eu un pronostic vital
engagé elle a été modernisée jusqu'au 8
mars et ensuite elle a fait deux jours
de néphrologie on est sorti le 15 mars
et là il ya une surveillance à la maison
pour l'instant la part commencé l'école
on a ça fait trop pour moi quel ordre
simplement depuis mois de février quand
est-ce que vous avez compris que c'était
la pizza bas au départ en fait je savais
pas à l'hôpital on va en faire encore un
questionnaire où on vous demandait de
remonter sur une semaine même les
médecins sur quinze jours de ce qu'elles
avaient mangé où on avait acheté toutes
les marques il fallait se rappeler tout
vous êtes rappelez vous à vous l'avez
mentionné la petite heure au départ ben
en fait elle était chez son papa donc
moi non et après son bain m'a dit oui
effectivement il ya des pizzas et la
dame de la res m'a appelé après au
niveau des prélèvements qui ont été
faits sur ma fille c'était les mêmes
prénoms en a été la même souche que la
bactérie de dépit des en fait c'est les
cheveux chaque oui
d'accord alors
donc votre fille ou comme vous me l'avez
dit elle elle risque d'avoir des
séquelles à vie oui nous pouvons dit les
paiements sepa en fait pour l'instant sa
fonction rénale l epa enfin au niveau
rénal c'est pas rentré dans l'ordre à la
des bilans qui baissent mais qui sont
pas vous même au niveau du sens pour
l'instant les treize années michalon
dialyse un nom elle est retournée à la
maison mais on a des des consultations
chez le généraliste toutes les semaines
à la des bilans sanguins des analyses
d'urines est elle un rendez-vous a en
effet frôlé ogi au mois de mai et on m'a
dit que tu façon ça serait un suivi à
vie et qu'au niveau des séquelles on
pouvait pas savoir que ce serait qu'elle
pouvait à récupérer comme elle peut
avoir des séquelles ça peut aller de la
tension artérielle à la greffe de rein
on m'a dit qu'il fallait que j'entende
ça et que c'était quelque chose que l'on
ne pouvait découvrir dans quelques
années ça peut être temps moi mais ça
peut être en année
il y avait d'autres gens qui à quelques
manger cette pizza forcément oui mon
autre fille ma fille aînée n'a rien eu
là rien eu non ça ne m'a pas qui en a
mangé et un autre enfant une dame mais
personne n'a rien vu on sent que et
c'est normal on se met tous à votre
place aujourd'hui s'il y en avait une
petite fille de 9 ans qui mange une
pizza et qui se retrouvent avec un
pronostic vital engagé dans un premier
temps et maintenant peut-être avec des
séquelles à vie
qu'est ce que vous aviez vous dit voici
ce que nous dira chez moi je me dis on
peut avoir confiance en personne en fait
sans rien c'est à dire que on essaye
voilà deux ans voilà on se dit on peut
aujourd'hui on entend tellement de
scandales alimentaires on se dit c'est
ccc c'est incroyable la vie votre vie
elle a basculé du jour au lendemain à
cause d'une pizza quoi oui c'est ça
c'est bonjour dit riboud donc c'est
assez compliqué la même main sur même de
faire à manger un de lui donner à manger
à rien sur moi c'est compliqué j'ai peur
c'est aujourd'hui vous l'avez expliquer
ce qui s'est passé ou ponelle s'est tous
bien sûr c'est tout elle en avait bien
conscience de toute façon et puis les
médecins ils ont toujours expliqué elle
me disait
il ya eu un moment elle m'a dit maman
d'ivoire parce que je vais mourir
donc c'est compliqué un nom nous a
demandé si nous avions elle vous dit ça
vous a demandé à l'ansés a les moyens
oui
aujourd'hui à vous demande si elle va
avoir des séquelles à vie forcément
maintenant elle a compris elle me dit
qu'elle me dit qu'elle sec et qu'elle
peut pas mourir de ça mais elle me
demande toujours est ce que je fais
c'est pipi est-ce que ce qu'elle
mangeait ce que c'est bon est ce que
j'ai le droit de manger ça s'est
compliqué hein c'est un traumatisme
incroyable pour pour pour elle pour vous
pour pour toute la famille aujourd'hui
vous avez vous avez porté plainte contre
la marque oui d'accord vous avez entamé
une action en justice n'a pas vraiment
longtemps fait au départ j'étais pas du
tout jeu c'était pas ma préoccupation à
mafia lester à l'hôpital j'en avais rien
à faire de ça et c'est normal à la
sortie de l'hôpital
sur facebook en fait il y avait un
groupe et ça je sors ton du silence donc
je suis rentré dans ce groupe en fait
pour parler que des parents tout
simplement des gens qui vivent ou qui
ont vécu déjà la même chose donc on a
discuté après il ya des mamans des papas
ils m'ont dit qu'il y avait un collectif
pour s'associer et pour avoir une action
en justice au
plus on était nombreux et mieux ça
serait aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois vous donner à manger à votre
fille vous aussi vous avez vous devez
vous êtes en panique ici c'est paris
c'est pas moi tu y est j'ai peur de
cesser là j'ai perdu donner à manger en
fait c'est terrible enfin ccc mais oui
c'est très très compliqué de lui donner
à manger alors maître richard legrand
est avec nous il va nous donner des
infos importantes vous êtes avocat de
plusieurs victimes de plusieurs familles
de victimes dans la sphère bitani est ce
qu'il s'agit du plus gros scandales
alimentaires en france actuellement
c'est un truc de fou oui sans
effectivement il semblerait que ce soit
le plus gros scandale sanitaire durant
les vingt dernières années
du fait de plusieurs facteurs notamment
du nombre de cas graves que nous avons
pu rencontrer
et la répartition à l'échelle nationale
du nombre de victimes et mais également
aussi les décès il ya eu des décès
malheureusement de décès
on voit là c'est
c'est malheureusement la loi des séries
on travaille de nouvelles le nouveau
scandale sanitaire notamment avec la
marque kinder est
ce qu'aujourd'hui
les la société bettoni à contacter les
victimes faites vous pas du tout non pas
du tout qui traite on n'a pas
connaissance de contacts directs avec
accor pas du tout de contact essayer de
voir comment on va commander votre fils
comment payer comme victime de ces
pouvoirs alors aujourd'hui ressent
actuellement on a une cinquantaine de
cas graves d'accord le syndrome
hémolytique et urémique donc la forme
pessah chu répartis sur tout le
territoire on a eu deux décès
malheureusement
alors au niveau des profits donc on a
majoritairement des enfants
mais aussi des adultes on ne faut pas
oublier les adultes qui ont signé des
formes graves
et c'est très important à souligner bien
sûr une enquête a été ouverte pour
homicide involontaire et ce qui est très
important ce qui pourrait faire
déboucher c'est qu'effectivement comme
vous le disiez ils ont unifié par le
pôle santé qui enquêtent au niveau
national donc c'est un pôle très
compétent sous l'égide du parquet de
paris et donc il ya plein d'eau 6 qui
enquête tous azimuts en france
gendarmerie mais le problème de ses
grandes marques c'est qu'on réagit c'est
après c'est à dire qu'on a l'impression
que ces grandes marques je suis pas
celle là particulièrement mais en toute
impunité finalement ne respectent pas
les règles sanitaires on trouve des
bactéries y en a plein en ce moment et
c'est impossible de prévenir et en ce
moment il ya une recrudescence t rès que
m les familles qui nous regardent ce
soir elles se disent comment je fais
maintenant même si ça moi je le vois moi
j'étais devant de pizzas que je pouvais
manger que je pouvais manger les enfants
moi je vois
ce qui arrive à la pauvre julia et
amélie et sa maman alors on se dit c'est
quand même fou notre vie bascule du jour
au lendemain parce qu'on a mangé une
pizza ont fait confiance et derrière nos
10 bascule et on peut gâcher la l'asie
d'une note note fille de 9 ans c'est
aujourd'hui on a peur de tout je vois ce
que disait amélie une ans dit on va
donner à manger là nos enfants à chaque
fois avec la peur au ventre donc m
qu'est ce qui va se passer
alors il y a eu des perquisitions
récemment donc à l' usine de caudry mais
également siège de nestlé à issy les
moulineaux qu'elles sont quels sont les
premiers premiers éléments qui sont
sortis lundi pour l'instant on n'a pas
d'élément par rapport à cela nous
souhaitons l'ouverture d'une information
judiciaire avec la désignation d'un ou
plusieurs juges d'instruction et ce qui
nous permettrait de pouvoir à ce que les
familles puissent se constituer partie
civile afin d'obtenir réparation des
préjudices qui ont été subies quand vous
dites préparation c'est quoi ces deux cd
dommages intérêts importants à chaque
famille tout dépend de la situation
médical de chacune chacune des victimes
la marque car voilà après les préjudices
ne sont pas simplement physique bien sûr
mais il ya aussi tout ce qui va autour
oui ce sont des vies brisées regardez
amélie briser la voile et
c'est atroce un traumatisme voilà c'est
un traumatisme à vie c'est l'avenir
aussi des projets professionnels aussi
qu'ils sont chamboulées notamment de
deux familles des familles perdu leurs
questions comme c'était immuable ça ou
est ce que ça vient d'un de problème
sanitaire qu'il y aurait dans les villes
gilles verdez parce que c'est vrai que
c'est ça aussi qu'on peut n'arrive pas à
savoir parce que des fois on nous disait
que c'était voilà qui avaient des
bactéries partout et que forcément
c'était un petit peu c'était dingue de
dire ça c'est un petit peu nous et
d'autres chansons alors on a quand même
l'impression qu'à chaque fois qu'on
remonte les chaînes de production on
découvre dans les usines notamment à
caudry dans le nord qui a été fermée
c'est pas pour rien que la production
est arrêtée on découvre des problèmes
d'hygiène on découvre il ya vu les
images vous souvenez on avait montré ses
des images terrifiantes à un moment on
les a derrière derrière la de deux
demandes hygiène de manque de respect
des protocoles dont on a l'impression
quand même que dans ses usines ou après
on a détecté des bactéries et où il ya
eu des drames on a l'impression d'
insuffisance au niveau de l'organisation
et de la vigilance mercredi dernier les
enquêteurs ont perquisitionné lusine but
tony de caudry inde en eau douce ou
fabriqués dans toutes les pizzas de la
gamme fraîcheur usine dont les salariés
témoignent des conditions d'hygiène
déplorables et se regarder à la vidéo de
la perturbation chine ne produit plus
haut qu'une pizza depuis le 1er avril
date d'un arrêté préfectoral
selon ce document les services
d'inspection alimentaires ont noté de
nombreuses anomalies graves la présence
de rongeurs un manque d'entretien et de
nettoyage un constat partagé par une
ancienne salariée de but tony elle
refuse d'être enregistrés mais accepte
de témoigner par téléphone le nettoyage
n'étaient pas faits en profondeur on
faisait le plus gros au plus vite le
travail était bâclé j'ai même été exclu
du poste de nettoyage parce que j'étais
trop longue
c'est intolérable de la course au profit
et gilles l'a dit alors en toute
impunité nous ont fait confiance aux
gens qui nous donnent à manger on peut
pas tous on doit tous avoir le petit
reste orateur déjà kiki qu'ils fassent
des conneries déjà c'est intolérable
qu'un petit restaurateur de nous
empoisonnent ou qu'ils respectent pas la
chaîne du froid vous respecte pas ses
cuisines mais des grands groupes comme
ça avec derrière en plus quelqu'un
d'autre derrière buitoni parce que
derrière d'autres ya derrière biteau dit
encore un autre grand groupe nous ont
fait confiance on achète des pizzas vous
rendez compte les drames qu'on parle 50k
juste parce qu'on a acheté des pizzas
nous consommateurs parce que veulent
faire des plus gros bénéfices pour se
dépêcher de nettoyer ou pas nettoyer
leurs entrepôts c'est scandaleux de
faire ça sans doute qui met nos vies en
danger moi je suis pour une loi ou ces
gens là ces gens là les responsables
c'est devant un tribunal et peut-être
même de la prison parce qu'on ne peut
pas jouer c'est la santé des gens il ya
des directeurs il ya des responsables si
vous voulez pas nettoyer vos entrepôts
vous allez vous présenter devant la
justice et vous allez avoir une peine
comme un criminel parce que c'est
criminel devra justement saint laurent
et il risque quoi les riches quoi alors
il risque une peine de prison en sable
oui là le luzi oui tout à fait
l'entreprise des responsables le
dirigeant de l'entreprise également tout
à fait oui il ya un risque ponsable
voilà tout à fait est bon il ya quand
même il faut savoir aussi que
les conditions d'hygiène déplorables
il ya une alerte plusieurs mois avant
que ce scandale arrive rien n'a été fait
rien n'a été fait mais un ancien salarié
qu'elle voit la vidéo on voit il a fallu
attendre qu'on en arrive à des des
formes graves ou des décès pour que
l'usiné enfin l'entreprise réagissait
alors on me dit aussi que l' usine
nuithonie de caudry est la seule en
france qui fabrique des pis sa fraîcheur
dont la pâte et surgelés cru et c'est
très sensibles pour la sécurité c'est ce
qu'on dira tout à fait voilà c'est ça
enfin oui évidemment que quand la pâte à
l'est et les surgelés cru ça pose un
problème mais là il y avait aussi
visiblement des problèmes d'hygiène
parce que les les images qu'on a vu on a
vu quand même des champignons au mur des
bouts de nourriture qui restait qui
visiblement était là depuis très
longtemps qu'ils n'avaient pas été
nettoyées on vous savez pour que la pâte
ne colle pas sur les tapis de production
normalement mettre la farine et avait
delà des verts de là dedans
et c'est donc là on est au delà d'un
piolet n'y a pas d'histoire servat ci
n'a pas d'histoire des surgelés si tu
suis la chaîne du froid mais un ton
camion il arrive il est des gens
surgelés ils rendent en entrepôt tout et
en surgelé il n'y a pas d'histoire c'est
pas en temps d'assimiler à praia dollars
de chaîne de froid c'est pas vrai si tu
fais bien ton travail si tu ne t'y tu
nettoies bien à chaque fin de trucs à
chaque chaîne comme tu dis si tu
balances de la farine si tu fais
vraiment les trucs dans les règles il a
ça ça n'arrive pas nous on est
consommateur on est là pour acheter un
produit et le manger pas pour acheter un
produit et mourir et quand vous dites
qu'il est responsable ils vont aller
devant les tribunaux ils seront les
prennent j'y crois pas une seconde alors
on va me trouver là dedans un petit
directeur de rien du tout un homme de
maïs on dira que ça met la faute mais
les grands grands et ils n'hésiteront
pas ce qu'est ce qui est le plus à une
romaine pas leurs skis le plus
hallucinant quand même c'est que les
personnes dans cette marque qui vous ai
contactés c'est ce qu'indique sa frappe
à tanger que personne parce qu'ils
dépendent des millions pour faire la
publicité me après la fin de la prison
téléphone pour dire excusez moi madame
peut-être qu'on va pouvoir faire quelque
chose pour vous comment est ce qu'on va
pouvoir vous aider parce que là on est
maire 2 on a merdé c'est notre faute
c'est mais moi j'aime et je me dis mais
comment mais avec l'abondance de l
allant vous l'aimez pas un club le
groupe nestlé en suisse veut fermer
cette usine c'est ce qui se dit depuis
longtemps vous êtes au courant de ça ou
pas
on a passé des aimants mais on sait
baluze in en tout cas a fermé assure la
ferme et un jean à faire mais voilà un
arrêté préfectoral donc le groupe nestlé
c'est con ce que je veux dire c'est très
très grave ce que je vais faire là non
plus le groupe nestlé va licencier des
gens à qui on a dit aux gens on
nettoiera demain et on se retrouve ils
vont faire mais pour aller où les gens
nestlé devant le bar nestlé pour faire
un coup et dire voilà c'est très très
con ce que je vais dire mais pour faire
un coup mon fère 2010 était déjà prévu
ce
qui la mettait en concurrence avec
d'autres entreprises ça dans d'autres
pays choix en allemagne roumanie ou en
suisse un bar en allemagne et ailleurs
en valeur en allemagne ces pourvois la
cc sont en concurrence avec d'autres
criaient d'autres inouï d'où l'idée que
l'entretien du site pour appuyer ce que
vous venez de révéler que l'entretien du
site n'aurait pas été à la hauteur des
attentes et des règles justement parce
que c'est mon cv délaissé presque
abandonné c'est ça le truc moi j'aime
tourner vers amélie qui est la maman de
julia qui voit là ce n'est plus
maintenant entre la vie la mort mais qui
risque d'avoir on n'espère pas en
histoire que tout va se passer bien se
passer pour juin mais qu'elle n'aura pas
des séquelles à vie voilà deux de cette
mésaventure
vous aujourd'hui à midi quand elle en
testant le temps l'on pense à ce que
vous vous rendez compte
de la réaction qu'elle peut avoir je la
trouve extrêmement calme je pense
vraiment que vous avez une réaction
vraiment
admirable parce que on se dit si ça nous
arrivait on entend oui mais parce qu'ils
vont faire mieux mais c'est sûr mais
qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout il facture les
pieds dedans mais ce qu'on voit c'est
que j'ai une petite fille il ya eu il ya
eu deux déjà eu deux desserts et yahia
ya une cité en état végétatif et sert
sur une enfant du siècle et ses
sympathies famille aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on me parle à moi ce que je veux
c'est ce que je vois c'est que ma fille
aujourd'hui elle est traumatisée à vie
on a on se demande tous les jours
comment elle va aller demain et on
apprend donc quand on n'a pas envie de
rentrer là dedans nous ont fait
confiance c'est tout c'est ça c'est
vraiment une pizza non mais c'est ça qui
est foot et a basculé en mangeant une
pudeur mais ccc grand décompte de la vie
votre vie a basculé aujourd'hui vous
êtes à ba1 on vivra plus jamais un
appareil se tiendra aujourd'hui vélia
c'est compliqué la nuit elle normale
elle a peur elle repense à ce qu'elle a
vécu et puis aujourd'hui c'est pas elle
a mal on fait parfois on retourne aux
urgences parce qu'elle fait des crises
ou les cachets laquelle me passe et tout
est compliqué hein tout est votre vie a
pris une tournure complètement
différente ans et non je pensais qu'à ça
vous voilà c'est au service et encore je
me dis que moi j'ai la chance d'avoir ma
fille ouais c'est ça c'est ça et
aujourd'hui vous vous battez pour
qu'elle aille mieux qu'elle s'en sorte
qu'elle n'ait pas de séquelles de de
cette affaire me connaît justement sur
les questions parce qu'il ya quand même
des cas la dévolution un peu difficile
lancement qu'elle les médecins nous
disent quoi qu'est ce qu'on sait de
l'évolution parce qu'un enfant qui est
en hémodialyse c'est quand même pas
anodin c'est c'est grave donc servir ses
reins ont été touchés c'est ça et qu'est
ce que les médecins vous disent qu'est
ce que vous savez ils me disent qu'ils
savent pas par exemple quand elle a des
bilans là tous les quinze jours on me
dit on n'applique pas dans les plis du
coup non la pique dans les mains si elle
doit être hémodialyse et à nouveau on me
dit qu'on peut pas savoir quand je
demande ça sera dans combien de temps on
me dit mais madame c'est peut-être pas
en moi c'est peut-être mon année je veux
dire et là on parle de cette affaire qui
est incroyable mais surtout
ça touche un problème d'état rien à
faire détails vous dire pourquoi
aujourd'hui pourquoi il se passe ça dans
l' usine bettoni en france
aujourd'hui elle n'était pas assez
rentable à cause du coût du travail et
que les salariés ont été trop cher à
l'entreprise pour faire les éclairant de
la rentabilité forcément il devait
couper des choses être moins vigilant et
et devait et ils ont commencé à décoller
délocaliser en allemagne en italie
aujourd'hui voilà ce qui arrive les
drames qui arrive quand on plus haut
niveau aussi ça bouge pas donc là on
espère que ça va bouger voilà et que les
responsables vont bouger parce que un
moment aussi
on en parle tout souvent on aimerait
aussi que tout le monde gagne mieux sa
vie mais il faut aussi que les
entreprises acquis aussi on a fait des
aides énormes redistribue à ceux qui
travaillent dans les lignes et les plus
démunis aujourd'hui pour la rentabilité
on met des vies en danger et aujourd'hui
je vous dire amélie on peut pas aller la
voir et lui dire ça aujourd'hui et lui
dire 1 bat julia elle a été victime d'un
problème de rentabilité c'est ça audible
c'est pas possible tu as problèmes de
charge de charges patronales elle
travaillait plus taxés en france le
travail est plus taxes en france vous ne
prenez pas à notre pays qui paye moins
taxe nous on paye le plus 2 plus de
taxes quant à des politiques qui
viennent et cyril suprême toujours des
exemples d autres villes les autres pays
regardaient en allemagne l'allemagne le
travail est moins chère à bien suite à
lille c'est pour ça qu'ils les
localisent dans les familles on a besoin
pour ça que toutes les entreprises de
bas et c'est pour ça qu'après on se
retrouve dans des cas comme ça parce
qu'on vend ça doit faire et bouger les
choses l'issue tout ce qui s'est passé
avant ça c'est pas possible c'est une
entreprise énorme aujourd'hui oui il
faut aider les pme il faut aider les
grandes entreprises faut aider avec
patron mais il faut que les patrons vont
distribuer je vous le dis parce que si
c'est pour faire encore plus de profits
et ne rien à distribuer ça sert à rien
ce sera toujours la même merde c'est ça
le problème il faudrait trouver un truc
où tu puisses vérifier aussi
l'échelle des salaires dans les
entreprises et voir si l'argent qu'on
leur a donné la baisse des charges sert
à quelque chose et qui est plus de
problèmes comme ça parce que ce n'est
pas ça ça c'est un problème ça tue vous
dire ça c'est un problème d'effectif
aussi c'est que voilà on réduit les
effectifs
les mecs ils sont ils sont ils seuls les
mecs j'ai bu tony ceux qui doivent
travailler dans les usines là bas et
qu'ils disent bas même aujourd'hui notre
culpabiliser les pauvres alors qu'ils
travaillent toute la journée voilà la
dame qui dit on m'a enlevé du poste de
nettoyage avait été trop lente elle a
bien sûr longue c'est pas possible on
parle toujours d'un an du cames et on
espère que ça va bouger
et surtout la seule chose qu'on espère
c'est que julia va aller mieux vous nous
donnerez des nouvelles oui amélie en
tout cas merci je sais que c'est très
très dur pompe ce que vous vivez
actuellement et on espère vous allez
trouver le courage et que julia valait
mieux est de mieux en mieux vous nous
donnerez vraiment des nouvelles c'est
important pour nous merci merci beaucoup